Chỉnh ám khi hoạt thủ đoàn tầm yên một trong năm sẽ chính giữ giữ giữ giữ giữ giữ giữ ngày 20 năm sau,
đến ngày 20 năm, ngày 20 năm năm, ngày 30 năm, ngày thúc trong ngày 20 năm,
tại bảo ra là đối.
Mở xa một công sản chẳng nhận đặc biệt, để cậm đồng cùng nghiệm về tương lai phát triển của đồ.
Gữa trở mình bị đại về công sản,
năm mở việc xa bỏ đưa duy đốt thì cách kiến đơn tự,
kiến tạo mua hình, chúng nó thì hướng tâm, lên kết hùng hành trình.
Hà Nội, thu đông ngàn năm quan hiện,
đáng đứa vào một tất mỗi mới,
với tầm yên dài hạt quan giận phạc bên bứng.
Trong hành trình ấy,
quy hành không chỉ là công trợ của không xa đồ thiệt,
hãy kết nối hạ tân,
mà còn là khách hà Nội,
xin giữ bản sách,
kiến tạo tươi cho khách hệ mai sau.
Ngày trẻ gám, những định hướng lớn trong phát triển thủ đồ,
sẽ được sĩ thiệu một khách chức quan,
xin đợp,
thông qua hệ thống xa bản quy hồ,
công nghệ trình chiếu,
và các trả nhận thị giác ấn tượng.
Dút tâm chúng hình dụng gió hơn,
về sĩ mặt thủ đồ trong một chăm năm tới.
Đó là một thà đồ yên quan hiện,
quanh mình hiện đại.
Một đồ thi khách triển 2 qua trên chiều sông năm năm lịch sử,
và các vọng thương tâm trong khiến với mới.
Chỉ là không chỉ là sự hiện có bố quý hạnh,
mà còn là lời mời gọi tốt đơn,
cũng quan tâm,
tộc hành,
và đống gốc vào hành trình đến tạo của đồ.
Chỉ là môi hoặc tụ đồ hành quý hạnh,
tâm vì một chăm năm,
giến ra từ ngày hai mi chính thẳng sấu,
đến ngày hai mi chính thẳng tâm năm năm năm năm,
nhìn khục chăm hai mi sấu,
tại bảo tâm thà nội.
Cười một nha năm,
cũng khúc chăm năm.